hello and welcome back to the shiki-san
show so today we're going to address the
question of what are the primary causes
of Aging
so last time I introduced you to the
hallmarks aging for which there are nine
different hallmarks and these different
hallmarks are categorized into three
different components the primary causes
of Aging
the antagonistic hallmarks and the
systemic or integrative hallmarks in
this video we'll just look at the
primary causes of Aging
the first of which is DNA or genetic
instability but how does this actually
contribute to aging so to understand the
involvement of DNA instability in aging
evidence that supports both increased
damage and advanced aging as evidence
showing that decreasing the damage
delays agent are needed so evidence for
the form of these comes from both
artificial induction of damage and
increased aging and from genetic
diseases such as progeria where
increased damage advances the aging
syndrome other cases where we know that
DNA mutations a form of DNA damage are
important for the C's progression are
seen in cancer and neuro degeneration
both associated diseases so how do you
even get DNA instability so this can be
split into two categories one of which
is intrinsic or endogenous damage the
other is extrinsic or exogenous damage
so the intrinsic or the endogenous
sources of damage includes reactive
oxygen species spontaneous damage and
also mutations that are going to kind of
craft from DNA replication errors the
extrinsic or exogenous sources of damage
includes UV radiation and chemical
exposure such as carcinogens and so
using one of our favorite model
organisms the mouse many genetic models
have been created to show you the role
of DNA instability in contributing to
agent for example
models with mutations in genes for p53
wanna and other helicases which are
genes and folds and the recognition
response and
Pera of DNA damage caused an accelerated
aging phenotype in the mice in addition
the same thing has been seen with
mutations in the protein that includes
the polymerase that replicates the
mitochondria DNA have also shown at an
accelerated aging phenotype in the mouse
so all of these studies really
demonstrates the role of genetic
instability in contributing to aging but
is this just the correlation or is it
actually a causation to really get an
understanding of this we really need to
have models whereby we can prevents
damage and see a reduced aging rate so
the next primary cause of aging is loss
of protein stages and so prou to stasis
takes into account the synthesis folding
and degradation of a protein and safe
for proteins to be functional they need
to be correctly folded hence lots of
protein stasis results in a loss of
function and this contributes to aging
so what actually happens during aging so
as you age there is generally seen any
reduced protein synthesis rates but also
if they reduce their rotation rates the
protein so this means that the actual
total level operating in a cell remains
the same however that pristine protein
has been present in the cell for a
longer time periods and during that time
micelle it could accumulate
modifications or become unfolded and
hence loses its function so whilst the
amount of protein may be the same the
proteins ability to function correctly
is reduced and so another consequence of
a protein being in the cell for a long
period of time is that it's more likely
to aggregate and aggregation of protein
is very key in aging phenotypes for
example neuro degeneration and outside
as disease you have aggregation of
amyloid beta and this aggregation is
thought to be the key trigger in the
development of Alzheimer's disease
evidence for the support of loss
approach a stasis and aging has also
come from another really famous model
organism the one or C elegans to be more
precise and so a study was conducted
whereby datak and all the protein from
either a young or an old
the elegans iams what they saw was that
there was an increased insoluble
proportion of protein at the later stage
of their life and insoluble protein
arises through aggregation hence you
have protein aggregation seems to be
correlating whether or not it's caused
causing but at least correlating with
the aging phenotype the next primary
cause of aging is telomere attrition so
telomeres are repetitive DNA sequences
that are found at the end of chromosomes
which are just large segments of DNA and
so they kind of act like sheep apps that
retain the integrity of the chromosome
however as you age things telomeres
shorten over time and so this integrity
gets lost this loss of integrity could
results in tumorigenesis therefore the
cell has mechanisms the kind of
capability lemurs
this mechanism is referred to as
cellular senescence or replicative
senescence in this case and so what this
means is that the cell can no longer
suffice and this prevents the cell from
increasing in the population but the
consequences you've lost the ability to
repair and regenerate tissue
however this replicative senescence only
occurs in cells that are actually
replicating the majority of cells in the
body and don't divide anymore yet they
saw age so how do they age obviously not
to read telomere attrition through
alternative mechanisms the point being
that telomere attrition early accounts
for certain cell types in certain
contacts and so it doesn't fully explain
the aging phenotype and so the cells are
likely aging in different ways including
hurons
muscle cells and heart cells so the last
primary cause of aging are epigenetic
changes so epigenetics refers to the
information that can be placed on top of
the genetic genome sequence so it can be
split down into three different
categories so you have DNA methylation
you can have modifications of proteins
called histones and so DNA is wrapped
around these histone proteins and the
last category is chromatin remodeling so
chromatin refers to both DNA and
histones as a complex and so the
contribution of changes and he's 30
people category
can results in a different gene
expression patterns it can result in
different DNA repair responses it can
alter the stability of the chromatin and
all of this can affect the function of
the cell and hence contribute to aging
but unlike DNA mutations epigenetic
changes are a fascicle and that's
exciting because if they are reversible
could there be mechanisms or ways that
we can alter the epigenetics to reverse
the effects that we see an aging
so the important take-home message is
that whilst there are many different
primary causes they are also more
interconnected and this can be
demonstrated through this and a diagram
here so during normal biology inevitable
that's--you accumulates damage and
either the proteins as we saw in
producers or in the DNA with DNA
instability and this can all result in
aging what happens is that this can be
advanced through other mechanisms that
we'll discuss in the next upcoming
videos such as inflammation and stem
cell loss and nutrient signaling that
also are important for understanding how
these different primary causes
contribute to the aging phenotype so
yeah there you have it DNA instability
loss of protein stasis telomere
attrition and epigenetic changes are the
primary causes for the aging phenotype